numbered Harris and I are live from
Bedford New Hampshire ahe of tomorrow's
first in the nation presidential primary
but Biden is not here he's getting back
from vacation today but not before he
took a swing at Republicans trying to
blame them for the Border
crisis I've been clear from the very
beginning the system is broken now the
question is for the speaker and the
House Republicans are they ready to act
as well they have to choose whether they
want to solve a problem or keep
weaponizing issues to score political
points to get the
president and when he was pressed on why
the Border not secure in his
administration Biden claimed it never
was to begin
with do you believe that that the border
is no it's not I haven't belied it the
last 10 years and I've said it for the
last 10 years give me the
money but Democrats and President
Biden's own party have had enough of him
playing politics with our Southern
border listen to Senator John fedman
warning that the neverbe seen surge of
migrants is threatening the American
dream I think two things can be true at
the same time you can be very supportive
of immigration but we also need to have
a secure border and I really I think
about immigration is we want to provide
the American dream for any migrant but
it seems very difficult when you have
300,000 people showing up encountered at
at a quarter to do that and Senator
fedman can not be more correct Harris
Let's Start with a fact check because
Biden said The Border's been unsecure
for 10 years we have a chart and it
shows apprehensions at the southern
border and look at those three yellow
bars that is under Biden a massive
number of apprehensions going all the
way up to 2 million in 2023
unfortunately delusion is not one of the
things on the list that you need to be
president and those are not percentages
polls or anything like that that the
White House likes to say through its its
folks people that they don't really
believe in or it's too far out those are
the raw data from the federal government
on people who've crossed into our nation
illegally Goda ways those numbers aren't
on that so just think about adding a
million more at least in the last year I
mean it it really is disturbing if you
cannot see what's going on how do you
fix it and then you have a zar she can't
fix it either and then you have a
Homeland secretary myor is who's under
impeachment inquiry right now he
obviously can't fix it either so whose
priority is our nation sovereignty
that's what I want to know who is it
really important to because if you're
president and the people that you've
tasked to fix a situation can't do it
then it falls to you and you can't be
falling down trying to fix it and I'm
not making fun of him I mean he's
falling down on the job that's what you
say about people who retire before your
eyes they're not doing their job he
needs to stand up get some intentional
fortitude and and do what's necessary
maybe you got to put back in place some
of those Trump policies that were
working that takes a man to do the job
right now I don't know what the child in
the White House is thinking yeah former
White House Press Secretary Jen saki had
some thoughts on the issue last night
let's
watch we all know the real reason Trump
wants to tank this deal he doesn't
actually care about solving the problem
at the border he wants the problem he
wants the issue to run on because it is
the fear-mongering the scare tactics
that he is betting on to excite his
voters and his base this deal is far
from perfect but if Trump is successful
in tanking this deal democrats should
not let voters forget it because Trump's
fearmongering about immigration his
constant drum beat about the Border will
continue all the way until the until
November I mean Emily it can be
dismissed as fear-mongering but polls
show The Border surging in importance to
voters and regardless of the
polls it's a destruction that is
affecting every American you know the
thing the Hallmark of this
Administration to me is this it's that
you know you sort of don't care about an
issue until it hits you personally until
it hits home and you can argue that
especially with this topic to your point
Kaylee as reflected in the polls it is
Paramount to every
American's priority list because it is
impacting every American regardless of
proximity to the southern border and
this Administration plays it off as
fear-mongering when people in Denver
have to wait for a bed because the
illegal immigrants have filled up the
hospital and the hospital has no
resources when people have to forego
buying certain groceries because of
inflation when they have to put their
kids in a different field because their
home field is all filled up the list
goes on of the priorities as executed by
this administration of everyone else but
Americans and they will tell you
repeatedly it is your fault it is your
fault that you chose to buy a truck with
gas it is your fault that you chose to
work in a factory it is your fault that
you have any choice whatsoever over
things you don't because to them it is
fearmongering rather than reality and
reality is Molly and Iowa are Fox News
voter analysis 41% said it was their top
issue here when you look at the Monmouth
poll in New Hampshire 25% say it's the
top issue 59% say it's a very important
issue yeah this is something that people
all across the country are caring about
we've seen big city Democrat leaders uh
talking to the president about this
saying we need help Blue State leaders
saying we need help and now it doesn't
democ in the House of Representatives
have joined with Republicans in this
resolution that's been put forward
denouncing the Biden administration's
current policy and they're from all over
the country by the way Alaska Maine
Florida this is something people across
the country are
pay we've lost Molly Lee your
thoughts the president when he comes
into office January 2021 claimed the
power and responsibility to open the
Border I mean he stops construction of
the border wall he ramps up Catch and
Release gets rid of Romania Mexico gets
rid of title 42 and now wants to act
like he doesn't have the power and
responsibility to fix it and wants to
punt to Congress he's wrong for doing it
yeah but it's all been going on for the
last 10 years has nothing to do with
Biden he tells us all right hey everyone
I'm Emily compano catch me and my
co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaylee mcki
on outnumbered every weekday at 12:00
p.m. Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights